- We taped an interview with
Tyra a few days ago though,
and she had this to say about you.
- Derek Hough is a new judge
this season on "Dancing With The Stars"
and so, I'm kinda tempted to ask him
to choreograph 16 counts for
me to see if I can do it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I haven't asked him yet,
but I'm asking you now Derek,
can you choreograph that for me?
(audience cheers)
- Oh boy.
- [Kelly] I'm just saying.
- You know--
- I told her
you should dance with her.
Do some kind of, I don't know--
- [Derek] We'll do it.
- TikTok moment, I dunno.
- I'm always down with it.
Here's the thing, I
don't need to teach Tyra
how to dance something, 'cause
she's already got it down,
she's got the walk, she's got the moves.
It's more about, whenever
people make mistakes
on the show, it's not
about how well you dance,
it's about how well you
cover up the mistakes, right?
So if she does her catwalk,
by the way, in my socks,
by the way.
- I love it!
And point those toes, point them!
- Yes, yes.
(both laugh)
I'm glad I wore socks today.
No, but you know, she's
walking, and if you trip
or something like that,
you just gotta like,
she does her little thing, she trips,
you gotta like--
- Oh my gosh.
- You've gotta make a move out of it.
- I'm not cool.
- But she already knows
that, she already knows that,
she's got it, yeah.
- That was so Patrick
Swayze, I just got lost
in "Dirty Dancing" again.
I'm gonna watch that tonight.